c'est sur le point d'être épique
c'est sur le point d'être fou
c'est sur le point d'être épiquement fou
dans l'ordre chronologique c'est le
deuxième film Transformers il se déroule
dans les années 90 peu de temps après un bourdon,
nous trouvons un enfant qui a du mal à savoir comment il est
capable de subvenir aux besoins de sa famille  mon
personnage, Noah, est un ancien militaire et j'ai l'
impression d'échouer à chaque instant,
puis je rencontre Mirage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était amusant mec,
voilà, maintenant nous sommes amis. Elena
travaille au musée, elle enquête sur
quelque chose qui amène Noah.  dans sa
vie, qui es-tu vraiment euh concierge et
cela nous ouvre un tout nouveau monde,
nous partons dans ce voyage fou avec les
Autobots, nous rencontrons les maximaux,
nous rencontrons le prochain niveau de sentiments, quelle
taille ce type peut-il avoir,
euh il mange des planètes  donc comme bien plus grand
qu'une planète,
beaucoup d'action, il y a de l'humour, un danger plus étrange
et il y a beaucoup de cœur,
ils vont à l'encontre du plus grand
effort de Nemesis, tout ce dont vous teniez à être
consommé, ils n'ont jamais fondé quelque chose
comme ça avant, laissez-les venir